bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
une séance dominée cet après-midi partie
par des interpellations des
parlementaires au gouvernement sur
notamment à la question de l'espace
schengen mais également la prime pour
l'emploi le pouvoir d'achat la baisse du
chômage au mois de mars dernier
et puis également des questions
concernant le sort des otages français
dans le monde
ou encore les révolutions arabes est une
conséquence l'immigration dans l'union
européenne
des questions d'actualité alors qu'on
vient d'apprendre qu'une explosion
meurtrière a eu lieu à l'heure du
déjeuner à marrakech au maroc
une explosion qui pour l'instant aurait
fait 14 morts et 23 blessés
on attend un petit peu plus de détails
notamment peut-être avec nos invités
après cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement via nos
recevront sur ce plateau des
parlementaires des membres du
gouvernement
ils nous donneront peut-être un peu plus
de détails sur cette explosion
meurtrière à marrakech tout de suite je
vous propose de rejoindre l'hémicycle du
sénat pour suivre cette séance présidée
par gérard larcher le président du sénat
avec en présence bien sûr d'une partie
importante des membres du gouvernement
et puis des sénateurs de tous bords
c'est le sénateur socialiste jean-pierre
sueur qui ouvre cette séance en
l'écoutant
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
j'aurais rappeler que l'auteur de la
question de même que là où le ministre
pour sa réponse disposent chacun de deux
minutes trente
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean pierre sueur pour le groupe
socialiste mais la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le pré
id en monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur vous le savez deux cent
mille réfugiés libyens ont été
accueillies en tunisie dans des
conditions difficiles et la tunisie a
fait tout ce qu'elle a pu
il y a des milliers de tunisiens qui
viennent aujourd'hui vers l'europe
souvent au péril de leur vie dans des
conditions très précaires
la première des choses que je voulais
vous demander monsieur le ministre c'est
comment pensez-vous agir par rapport à
ces personnes la responsabilité et nous
y tenons
mais nous tenons aussi beaucoup à la
fraternité comme l'a dit bertrand
delanoë vous le savez en second lieu la
position de la france par rapport à ces
pays je pense particulièrement à la
tunisie les tunisiens ont recouvré la
liberté
avec leurs mains nues et le gouvernement
français l'a reconnu avec un peu de
retard mais les tunisiens sont là sur ce
chemin
est-ce que la seule parole qui peut
apparaître dans les médias de france de
tunisie et du monde sait que certains
veulent les renvoyer à la mer bien sûr
c'est indigne
ce n'est pas possible monsieur le
ministre vous le savez bien
enfin je voulais vous interroger par
rapport à nos responsabilités européenne
schengen ce fut une grande avancée c'est
toujours une grande avancée vouloir
mettre fin à schengen détruire porter
atteinte à schengen serait à coup sûr
une erreur car ce serait comme ans et de
défaire l'europe
donc on est pour schengen vous êtes pour
schengen mes chers collègues et c'est
très bien ainsi
donc je veux vous demander monsieur
le ministre quelles initiatives vous
allez prendre pour conforter l'espace
européen faire qu'il y ait une politique
d'immigration qui soit commune est porté
par l'ensemble des pays et faire aussi
qu'il y est un vaste plan dans l'europe
qui soient forts qu'ils soient
dynamiques pour que l'on vienne en aide
à la tunisie a tous ces pays qui aspire
au développement devrait avec eux pour
leur développement économique
c'est aider à trouver de vraies
solutions aux problèmes qui se posent
monsieur le ministre la voix de la
france elle est très importante
l'attitude de la france aussi nous
espérons vivement qu'elle sera faite de
responsabilité mais aussi de fraternité
car nous sommes la france pour vous
répondre
la parole est à monsieur claude guéant
ministre de l'intérieur et donc le trop
versé collectivités territoriales et de
l'immigration
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs comme vous monsieur sueur le
gouvernement se réjouit de ce que la
tunisie accède à une ère nouvelle de sa
vie et qui est une vie de liberté et une
vie démocratique c'est bien la raison
pour laquelle la france souhaite
apporter un concours sous bien des
formes à la tunisie pour amorcer cette
vie nouvelle et aussi pour définir et
conforter son développement économique
c'est la raison pour laquelle alain
juppé était en tunisie voici quelques
jours cela étant nous n'entendons pas
subir des vagues de migration qui ne
sont que justifiée par des motifs
économiques
il serait paradoxal que nous accueillons
des gens qui précisément viennent d'un
pays qui s'ouvrent à la liberté qui
s'ouvre à une ère dans laquelle il n'y a
plus de pression et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la france refuse que les
clandestins entrent dans notre pays et
je suis surpris que des parlementaires
invite à ce que les lois de la
république ne soit tout simplement pas
appliqué
en ce qui concerne schengen la france et
le gouvernement français est extrêmement
attaché à cette conquête européenne
schengen c'est un espace de libre
circulation et avec l'euro cette espace
de libre circulation est une des grandes
conquêtes de l'europe et c'est
précisément pour sauver cet espace que
la france avec l'italie prendre des
initiatives
l'allemagne le royaume uni travaille
aussi avec nous bien que le royaume uni
ne soit pas membre de schengen du reste
mais il n'empêche que nous travaillons
dans le même sens que faire d'abord
faire en sorte que l'espace schengen se
dote de mécanismes efficaces de
protection des frontières
cela signifie un renforcement des moyens
de frontex
cela signifie aussi une amélioration de
la gouvernance qui commandent schengen
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas du tout évident
pour dit que ce soit il faut que le
conseil justice et affaires intérieures
créer une instance avec des séances
spécifiques pour gouverner schengen il
faut des mécanismes d'évaluation de la
réalité du contrôle aux frontières
extérieures par les pays qui sont des
pays d'entrée et il faut également que
nous amorcions cette garde des
frontières européennes qui est souhaitée
depuis tant d'années un autre collègue
madame marie-france beaufils pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
sénateurs du parti de gauche
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
à peine plus d'un an des prochaines
élections présidentielles le président
de la république semble redécouvrir que
la préoccupation première de nos
concitoyens demeure et de loin leur
pouvoir d'achat
cela se conçoit puisque tout temps de
travail confondus
40% des hommes et 50 % des femmes
gagnent moins de 1200 euros par mois au
lieu du partage des bénéfices en trois
tiers promis il propose une prime
exceptionnelle de 1000 euros tout au
plus et qui ne concernera que les
salariés des entreprises de plus de 50
dans les dividendes versés aux
actionnaires ont augmenté
l'immense majorité des salariés de notre
pays ne bénéficiera ni de cette prime ni
d'une réelle revalorisation du smic
celles prévues couvrent à peine
l'inflation je rappellerai quelques
chiffres + 3 % sur les produits frais en
mars + 5 % pour les pâtes + 5 % pour le
pain entre 2 et 4% pour le fromage
annonce la fédération du commerce
l'octroi d'un chèque bienvenue pour ces
salariés ne masque pas les dégâts de
votre politique ni les fins de mois
difficiles qui s'inscrivent elles dans
la durée les organisations syndicales
mais aussi les français et en nombre ne
sont pas dupes ils savent que le
président fait mine de se préoccuper de
leur pouvoir d'achat
alors qu'il s'apprête à faire cadeau aux
plus riches de la caci quasi suppression
de l' isf
il veut éviter d'aborder la vraie
question celle d'une juste rémunération
du travail et d'une répartition des
richesses plus équitable
de plus monsieur le premier ministre
pour que les salariés puissent espérer
bénéficier d'une légère prime il faut
impérativement que les actionnaires
gagnent toujours plus voilà votre
conception du partage des richesses
les salariés ont accru leur productivité
en france
cela a permis d'augmenter
considérablement la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises
au point que les bénéfices des sociétés
du cac 40 a fait un bond de 85 % en 2010
leurs dirigeants ont vu leur
rémunération augmenter de 24% l'an
dernier la part consacrée aux
actionnaires et remboursements bancaire
a progressé de 14% entre 92 et 2009 dans
la répartition de la valeur ajoutée
les salariés ont donc bien droit à une
augmentation immédiate et générale des
salaires seuls modes légitime de
rémunération de leur travail
ma question est donc simple qu'attendez
vous pour instaurer le smic à 1600 euros
pour augmenter le traitement des
fonctionnaires et ainsi déclencher
l'augmentation générale des salaires
ne serait ce pas le meilleur signe que
vous vous préoccupez du pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur xavier bertrand ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la santé
merci monsieur le président l'âme ces
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur
le regard que vous portez sur le partage
de la valeur s'arrête juste à la théorie
et ne passent pas la pratique en aucune
façon en aucune façon parce que nous
avons nous un raisonnement qui est très
simple et qui dépasse même la seule
question du pouvoir d'achat
si dans une entreprise les bénéfices
progressent c'est grâce bien sûr à
l'actionnaire qui a fait une mise de
départ de l'entreprise
mais c'est aussi grâce aux salariés et
ce qui nous intéresse nous c'est que si
la valeur progresse pour l'actionnaire
le salarié en profite également
la seule différence c'est que vous vous
êtes dans une théorie dépassé depuis
maintenant le siècle dernier sinon plus
loin nous sommes nous dans le principe
de réalité
il y aura bien un texte dès cette année
qui permettra justement d'avoir un autre
partage de la valeur et que en plus en
plus du salaire en plus du salaire il y
ait une prime qui soit versée au salarié
le montant
les modalités seront déterminées seront
fixés dans l'entreprise par le dialogue
social par les partenaires sociaux
mais force est de reconnaître que si le
gouvernement n'avait pas pris ses
responsabilités pour donner suite à la
volonté du président de la république
les discussions seraient toujours enlisé
et rien n'aurait avancer parce qu'il
faut aussi reconnaître que sur ce sujet
certains acteurs notamment comme le
medef n'ont pas engagé les négociations
nécessaires nous prenons nos
responsabilités
il y aura toujours la place pour la
négociation au niveau national également
dans les entreprises mais nous voulons
que les choses changent et l'autre part
je tiens aussi à vous le dire le salaire
est important et pour le salaire ya ceux
qui ont parlé à ceux qui agissent dans
la suite de ce que le président larcher
avait fait quand il était ministre
aujourd'hui dans les branches
professionnelles il y a les négociations
annuelles obligatoires
c'est nous qui l'avons mis en place que
par ailleurs sur tous ces sujets nous
sommes nous au rendez-vous d'injuste et
d'un meilleur partage et concernant
notamment la question du pouvoir d'achat
vous avez omis dire une chose où on
serait le pouvoir d'achat des français
si le gouvernement n'avait pas pris ses
responsabilités au
coeur de la crise quand il a fallu aider
notamment les français les plus modestes
et les salariés les plus modestes
s'il n'y avait pas eu toutes ces
décisions mais vous avez la mémoire
courte
nous n'aurions pas été en mesure de
préserver notre pacte social
mais la vérité c'est que le principal
ennemi du pouvoir d'achat pour les
français ce sont les impôts
il est vrai qu'en la matière communistes
et socialistes sont les champions en
matière d'imposition
voilà l'ennemi du pouvoir d'achat vous
êtes les ennemis du pouvoir d'achat
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à monsieur ou président jean bizet pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole monsieur
le président merci monsieur le président
sur le président messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur de l'outre-mer des
collectivités territoriales et de
l'immigration
les événements qui se déroulent en
afrique du nord suscitent des réactions
où se mêlent l'espoir et l'inquiétude
espoir de voir cette région évoluer vers
la démocratie et vers plus de prospérité
inquiétude devant le risque pour l'union
européenne dans un contexte de grande
instabilité d'être confronté à des
mouvements migratoires importants et
difficiles à maîtriser
dans ce contexte se pose la question
cruciale des modalités de mise en oeuvre
des accords de schengen
le tout récent sommet franco italien
s'en est fait l'écho en se prononçant
pour une réforme de schengen qui
permettent de le renforcer
compte tenu de l'importance de cette
question la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat a décidé avec son
homologue de l'assemblée nationale de
mettre en place un groupe de suivi qui
pourrait réfléchir à des clauses de
sauvegarde de sauvegarde renforcer en
cas de défaillance des contrôles des
frontières extérieures ainsi qu'à la
nuit tu alisation européenne accrue des
moyens nationaux humains et matériels de
contrait de contrôle des frontières de
l'union
ainsi monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous rappeler la position du
gouvernement sur les conditions de mise
en oeuvre des accords de schengen face
au mouvement
migratoire récents en méditerranée et
indiquer quelles seraient les mesures
qui vous semblerait nécessaires pour
renforcer les conditions d'application
de ces accords pour vous répondre la
parole est à monsieur claude guéant
ministre de l'intérieur des
collectivités territoriales et de
l'immigration sur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean bizet je voudrais tout
d'abord vous donner quelques indications
sur la façon dont le gouvernement entend
que soient mises en oeuvre aujourd'hui
les accords de schengen
il suffit à venir de s'en tenir à leur
lettre la lettre des accords de schengen
celle que le premier pays d'entrée gère
les entrées sur son territoire et la
lettre de ces accords c'est aussi qu' il
doit y avoir une coopération loyale
entre les pays nous avons pu déceler de
la part de nos amis italiens
quelques tentatives ou tentation de
renvoyer chez nous des personnes qu'ils
devaient gérer en application des
accords nous sommes tombés d'accord sur
la façon d'appliquer le traité et sa
convention d'application et donc nous
reconduisons en italie les personnes qui
ne disposent pas des ressources
nécessaires pour vivre en france et qui
vont dans les moins titulaires d'un
titre de séjour en italie
alors maintenant comment faire évoluer
les règles il faut les faire évoluer
pour sauver les accords de schengen
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
cela dans cinq directions ce sont les
propositions que nous avons faites au
conseil et à la commission en accord
avec l'italie d'abord renforcer l'
agence frontex qui est chargé du
contrôle des frontières extérieures
concrètement il s'agit de faire en sorte
que par exemple à l'égard de
l'immigration venant de tunisie
frontex puisse organiser des patrouilles
maritimes afin de l'interdire
la progression vers l'italie et
éventuellement de porter secours aux
personnes qui sont sur les bateaux
deuxième idée créer un noyau dur d'un
système européen de garde frontières
j'y faisais allusion tout à l'heure si
nous voulons que la confiance revienne
entre les pays
il faut en arriver là troisième idée un
mécanisme d'évaluation pour que chaque
pays soit rassuré
sur la pratique des autres quatrième
orientation retenir la possibilité à
titre exceptionnel de rétablir le
contrôle aux frontières
s'il y a un risque systémique de grande
ampleur que nous n'avons eu aura river
que nous n'arrivons pas à gérer et puis
5e orientation doter l'espace de
schengen d'une véritable gouvernance
aujourd'hui le conseil justice et
affaires intérieures s'en préoccupent de
temps à autre pendant quelques minutes
l'ordre du jour extrêmement chargé eh
bien il faut que ça change de dimension
et de tout cela il sera question à
bruxelles le 12 mai lors d'un conseil
justice et affaires intérieures
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
maintenant et notre collègue denis
detcheverry pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole vous chers
collègues si monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur de l'outre-mer
des collectivités territoriales et
concerne la très grave crise que
traverse le secteur de la pêche à saint
pierre et miquelon et avec lui
l'ensemble de l'économie de l'archipel
jadis très importante usine de
transformation à saint pierre et
miquelon la société actuelle spm seafood
se trouve dans une situation alarmante
il s'agissait pourtant d'une fin
prévisible avant même que layton décide
de donner les clefs de l'ancienne
entreprise interpelle à des canadiens la
majorité des représentants locaux
étaient défavorables à une reprise
perpétuant un système insoutenable car
trop basé sur du social sans réelle
vision économique ni à moyen ni à long
terme
en même temps c'est exactement ce qu'ont
fait les gouvernements successifs depuis
1992 le maintien de la paix sociale a
été privilégiée au détriment de la mise
en place d'un système économique viable
et durable
les saint pierrais mitonné qui était
connue et reconnue par le sens de
l'effort et du travail bien fait ont été
plongés dans un assistanat improductifs
réducteur dégradants et néfastes à long
terme
il faut dire que déjà à l'époque les
motivations étaient politiques qu'on a
préféré sacrifier saint pierre et
miquelon et sa population dont l'espoir
vain de vendre des airbus et des tgv au
canada pourtant les solutions était
simple une diversification de la pêche
et de notre système économique était
tout à fait possible
la prospérité dans les provinces
canadiennes voisine on est la première
preuve aujourd'hui alors que la france
ne produit que 15% de sa consommation de
produits de la mer sa fille rémy clan
collectivité française n'a pas les
moyens ni de valoriser unis d'exporter
la richesse qui existent encore sur les
bancs de terre-neuve même l'avenir la
culture qui l'a fait l'objet
d'investissements privés importants et
de recherches poussées semble incertain
pourtant de nombreux rapports
scientifiques sur nos ressources et
notre potentiel halieutique existe et
indique la marche à suivre
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons une
faute plus dans l'impasse
parce que des choix ont été faits basée
uniquement sur des appartenances sur une
appartenance partisane quelques calculs
politiques ce n'est pas l'idée que je me
fais de la république et de la défense
de l'intérêt général qui nous anime dans
cette enceinte
il est urgent de réponse et la filière
halieutique dans son ensemble et de
manière objectif sur le ministe
pouvez-vous m'assurer d'un réel soutien
technique et d'un réel suivi des
services de l'état afin que nos choix
économiques sont fins basée sur les
faits et selon là une seule la seule
logique économique
finissons-en avec toutes ces erreurs à
répétition avec tout ce gaspillage
financier de non lieu ou mir et l île
durable de saint pierre et miquelon sur
le ministre mes chers collègues saint
pierre et miquelon territoire de la
république française ville de son
travail pour vous répondre la parole est
à monsieur claude guéant ministre de
l'intérieur de l'outre-mer
monsieur le président il y aura la
parole monsieur le sénateur detcheverry
le gouvernement c'est bien l'importance
de la filière pêche pour
saint-pierre-et-miquelon et il sait bien
aussi les difficultés que l'archipel
rencontre depuis des années le début des
années 90 quand est intervenu le
moratoire est depuis 2009 il y un
soutien très important qui comme vous le
savez est apportée à la modernisation de
l'outil de production des différentes
entreprises de la filière halieutique au
côté de
la collectivité territoriale le pôle de
transformation de saint pierre a été
repris vous l'avez rappelé par une
société canadienne
cette reprise vous le savez a été
validée de manière complètement
transparente par le tribunal de première
instance de saint-pierre qui statuait en
matière commerciale
au terme d'une procédure de redressement
judiciaire
tout à fait classique la société
seafoods néanmoins a accumulé des pertes
importantes n'a pas pu réaliser son plan
d'affaires et un rapport commandé par
marie luce penchard sera disponible la
semaine prochaine d'ailleurs qui
expliquera comment on est arrivé à cette
situation
l'entreprise s'est déclarée en cessation
de paiement il ya deux semaines il était
bien clair monsieur le sénateur que
l'état apportera tons chauds soute tout
son soutien technique opérationnel
financier pour mettre en place un projet
économique viable durable valide
il est effectivement extrêmement
important aux yeux du gouvernement que
soit garanti la pérennité d'une filière
pêche active à saint pierre et miquelon
le préfet a été mandaté pour consulter
sans tarder les différents acteurs de la
filière
le mandataire judiciaire sera nommé à
l'animé et bien entendu les élus seront
également consultés il faudra bien sûr
trouver un repreneur
j'ajoute qu'il semble important qu'il
puisse y avoir aussi une coordination
plus assurée entre les deux pôles de
transformation de saint-pierre et demi
que l'on j'ajoute qu'un spécialiste de
la filière sera mandatée par l'état pour
accompagner concrètement le plan de
rénovation se munissent la parole est
maintenant notre collègue jean boyer
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
chez le président chain ministre
mesdames messieurs chers collègues mes
cordes vocales sont défaillantes
mais je pense que je vais appeler
leur vitalité pour me faire entendre et
monsieur le ministre surtout pour me
faire comprendre
monsieur le ministre nous le 120 ou le
savon et je suis solidaire de cette
réalité pour la comprendre nos budgets
sont difficiles mais nous savons aussi
il doit y avoir des priorités afin de ne
pas qu'on porte compromettre l'avenir
notre société certes malade mais elle ne
semaine sera t'elle pas plus si les
élèves d'aujourd'hui travaillent dans
des classes surchargées loin de chez eux
loin de cette proximité indispensable
8200 pense supprimés dans le primaire
monsieur le ministre c'est un orage de
grêle sur les grandes parcelles de blé
se met dans la france permettait la sur
le ministre le message d'un ancien
régulateur dans certains secteurs
les machines peuvent remplacer les
hommes mais surtout pas dans
l'enseignement ou la mission des
enseignants deviendra de plus en plus
difficile voire à une rate permettez
monsieur le ministre
quand des élus d'un département rural
vous adresse un appel aux que vous
adressent un message qui est un appel
oui l'école constitue le dernier lieu
d'un service au public
elle est un élément d'ancrage
fondamentales de la vie locale dans nos
petites communes
dans celle ci les maires ou toujours
donné une priorité à l'école car ils
savent que c'est un investissement
primordial et incompressibles pour
demain chers collègues que vous soyez de
ce côté de l'hémicycle ou de celui ci
dans notre jeunesse
l'école a été notre deuxième famille
elle nous a aidés à devenir des hommes
et des femmes car notre enseignement été
personnalisés il y avait pas un
enseignant pour 20 ou 30 élèves
il était personnalisé et l'enseignement
nous était donné généreusement alors ne
vaut-il pas mieux aujourd'hui payer des
enseignants que deuxième sur le ministre
être obligé et je fais aucune démagogie
de prévoir un peu partout des éducateurs
spécialisés et peut-être sans dramatiser
des policiers la société de même que le
ministre se bâtit aujourd'hui et l'école
j'en suis convaincu et vous aussi en est
le meilleur des artisans en 1944 albert
camus qui était un enseignant
résistantes à partir du chambon sur
lignon haute loire un des plus beaux
bastion de la résistance
n'at-il pas dit la meilleure générosité
envers l'avenir c'est de donner beaucoup
au présent sincèrement chers amis
aujourd'hui l'école de 50 ans est passée
mais elle doit s'adapter
je vois monsieur le président que la
pendule tourne je droit que nous avons
que nous devons regarder monsieur le
ministre est placé à qui les dépasse et
avec des maîtres ou des kilos mais que
nous vous devons avoir au regard social
or répandre le cancer des enseignants
des parents et des élèves
merci de me dire monsieur le ministre
qu'est ce que vous envisagez de faire
bien pour vous répondre par l'état
monsieur luc chatel ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
de la vie associative
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur boyer le gouvernement partage
l'ambition que vous portez pour l'école
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il a
présenté ici même au sénat mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
cette année le budget le plus important
jamais défendu pour le système éducatif
62,5 milliards d'euros je rappelle que
c'est 21% du budget de la nation et que
depuis 1980 monsieur le sénateur le
budget par élève a augmenté en euros
constants de 80% 80% vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur d'être vigilants à
l'encadrement et jeu
vous rassurer en vous disant qu'à la
rentrée prochaine il y aura trente cinq
mille professeurs de plus qu'il y en
avait il ya vingt ans dans le système
éducatif
alors qu il y a cinq cent cinquante
mille élèves de moins vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur d'être vigilant sur
le nombre d'élèves par classe et là
aussi je veux vous rassurer puisque nous
aurons à la rentrée prochaine environ 25
élèves par maternelle en moyenne il y en
avait 27 ans 1990 nous aurons environ 22
élèves dans les écoles primaires et dans
la v 23 en 1990 et c'est une moyenne
nationale donc dans certains
départements ruraux comme la haute-loire
dont vous êtes l'élu monsieur le
sénateur nous aurons vingt élus grain
élèves par classe à la prochaine rentrée
en moyenne dans les écoles primaires
alors monsieur le sénateur je pense que
l'enjeu majeur aujourd'hui du système
éducatif
c'est d'être capable de faire en sorte
que chaque élève sortent de l'école
primaire en sachant lire écrire et
compter
c'est la loi fillon de 2005 les
fondamentaux
pour cela nous avons mis en place depuis
2008 un système d' aide personnalisée où
chaque élève qui rencontrent des
difficultés à l'école reçoit une
remédiation deux heures par semaine d'
aide à la lecture au sein du système
éducatif
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
mis en place des stages de soutien
scolaire 230 mille élèves en ont
bénéficié l'année dernière au sein du
système éducatif pour faire en sorte que
ceux qui ont des difficultés
eh bien on leur apporte davantage c'est
ça l'école de la république
être capable de faire davantage pour
ceux qui ont des difficultés et vous le
voyez monsieur le sénateur c'est la
politique que nous poursuivons
n'oublions pas que de nombreux pays dans
le monde ont de meilleurs résultats que
le système éducatif français alors
qu'ils consacrent moins de crédits à
l'éducation nationale ça doit nous
interpeller pour faire une politique
éducative qualitative sur mesure
adaptées à la situation de chaque élève
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue david
assouline pour le groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mon cher coll
mes chers collègues 485 oui 485
c'est le nombre de jours de détention de
stéphane taponier et hervé ghesquière
enlevés en afghanistan en compagnie de
leurs trois accompagnateurs alors qu'ils
réalisaient un reportage pour notre
télévision de service public comme de
nombreux journalistes dans le monde
là où il ya des guerres là où il ya des
révolutions là où la presse ces maillots
né et où on risque sa vie à exercer tout
simplement ce métier ils ont voulu nous
informer et je veux le dire avec force
et au nom de tout mon groupe socialiste
et apparentés ils remplissaient une
mission d'intérêt général nous informer
d'une guerre où nos forces armées que je
salue sont engagés avec des pertes
humaines régulière sans que l'on sache
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui mais c'est une
autre histoire
pourquoi elles y sont encore et pour
combien de temps
ma question monsieur le ministre a tout
d'abord vocation à parler d'eux ici au
parlement avec la force indispensable
que les politiques de notre pays doivent
manifester au diapason des innombrables
initiatives locales et citoyennes comme
les dix mille dessins d'enfants dont
certains sont exposés depuis ce matin
parce que le pire pour stéphane et hervé
comme pour les autres otages français
retenus par aqmi au niger
le pire pour eux serait l'oubli ou
l'habitude de leur absence
que pouvez vous nous dire de leurs
conditions de détention des espoirs que
nous avons de les voir libres le plus
vite possible des conditions posées par
leurs geôliers pour leur libération de
ce qui est fait sera fait par le
gouvernement pour que leur vie ne soit
pas mise en danger
et qu'ils soient libérés je vous pose
les mêmes questions bien sûr pour nos
otages retenus à l'étranger
mais si aujourd'hui je vous parle
particulièrement de stéphane taponier et
hervé ghesquière c'est que nous
constatons qu alors que se développent
des gigantesques nouveaux moyens de
communication citoyenne dont se
saisissent les peuples les jeunes pour
demander la démocratie partout dans le
monde
à quel point la liberté de la presse est
menacée
à quel point sa vue à la violence d'état
comme en russie en chine hier en egypte
bien sûr en libye et en syrie
aujourd'hui où ils sont interdits
d'exercer et/ou entre autres le
journaliste algérien khaled si mohamed
qui travaille pour france culture est
arrêtée depuis le 9 avril dernier
que pouvez-vous nous dire sur les
actions entreprises par votre
gouvernement dans les instances
internationales dans les relations avec
les états concernés pour que cette
liberté fondamentale consubstantiel de
la démocratie qui est celle d'informer
soit respectée et que la vie de celles
et ceux qui exercent ou plus noble
métier les journalistes soient protégés
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur henri de raincourt ministre
chargé de la coopération
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
vous remercie je vous remercie
c'est vrai dans l'avenir aussi c cnet je
remercie monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais remercier monsieur le
sénateur david assouline de la question
qu'il a posée et qui nous permet
effectivement en cet instant d'avoir une
pensée très forte à l'égard de nos deux
compatriotes qui sont retenus en otage
en afghanistan depuis presque vous
l'avez dit 500 jours c'est énorme c'est
moralement physiquement pour eux sans
doute à la limite de ce qui est
supportable et tout le courage qu'ils
manifestent doit être saluée par
l'hommage unanime de la représentation
nationale
vous me permettrez également
d'associer dans cet hommage le courage
de nos autres compatriotes qui sont
détenus dans d'autres parties du monde
vous y est fait référence et nous
pensons aussi très fort je peux vous
dire que le gouvernement français comme
tous les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé et c'est l'honneur de notre
république sont mobilisés seconde après
seconde
que ce soit le ministère des affaires
étrangères que ce soit le ministère de
la défense que ce soit le premier
ministre que ce soit le président de la
république pour faire tout ce qui est en
notre pouvoir pour avoir les meilleures
possibilités de d'entrevoir la
libération prochaine et de tous nos
otages et dans des conditions qui soient
acceptables par les uns et par les
autres
donc c'est un travail de tous les
instants vous nous demandez des
informations beaucoup ici ont exercé des
responsabilités gouvernementales et vous
savez que c'est très difficile d'en
donner parce que d'abord nous ne les
avons pas tout elles ne sont pas toutes
vérifiées et pas tout fiable et puis le
débat entre la sécurité et la discrétion
n'est jamais vraiment définitivement
tranché donc ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que les familles sont informées
jour après jour de tous les morceaux
d'informations que nous pouvons ici ou
là récoltés et je vous demande de nous
faire confiance parce qu'avec vous nous
avons son partage la volonté très forte
de ramener à la maison
nos compatriotes qui en ont été
injustement éloigné pour le reste vous
avez raison aussi de saluer le travail
des journalistes dans cette période
difficile et je veux vous dire que la
france n'est pas inactif soit au conseil
de sécurité où nous avons pris des
initiatives dès 2006 soit plus récemment
s'agissant de la résolution 1973
pour ce qui concerne la situation en
libye et donc comme vous nous
considérons qu'un des éléments
fondateurs de la démocratie c'est la
liberté de la presse et il irait
il ne saurait y avoir des pays qui
pourraient s'en exonérer
nous avons aussi en partage surtout ces
bandes bel idéal
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant monsieur alain fouché pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
pour deux minutes trente joueurs de
chacun nous respecter son temps monsieur
le président monsieur minutes ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du travail et de l'emploi après
une année 2009 difficile pour l'emploi
en france 2010 n'a pas été épargné par
les effets de la crise nous avons subi
une augmentation de 5,3 pour cent l'an
dernier
une homme d'inscrits sur les listes de
pôle emploi
d'autres pays certes connaissent des
difficultés plus forte dose ont moins de
difficultés mais d'autres pays connaît
des difficultés notamment si l'on
regarde nos voisins européens l'espagne
qui est un taux de 20,2 pour cent ou
l'irlande qui un taux de près de 15%
la politique sociale française unique au
monde
revenu de solidarité active politique
familiale régime d'indemnisation chômage
à mieux protéger qu'ailleurs les
demandeurs d'emploi ou l'évoquiez tout à
l'heure toutes les mesures en faveur de
l'emploi commencent à porter leurs
fruits
comme vous l'avait annoncé hier le mois
de mars vient de voir une nouvelle
baisse significative du nombre de
chômeurs 0,8 pour cent de demandeurs
d'emploi en moins sans activité
s'il semble désormais apparaître que
nous nous dirigeons vers la fin de crise
nous ne saurions relâcher les efforts
menés en faveur d'une véritable
politique pour l'emploi
en effet nous le voyons tous les jours
sur le terrain les français ressentent
encore un sentiment d'inquiétude face à
sète fébrile reprises
une récente étude de l'insee montre que
d'ici à 2025 la france va gagner 110
milles active par an c'est un signe très
positif pour la santé de notre pays
mais les créations d'emplois doit suivre
en janvier monsieur le ministre vous
aviez fait savoir que mobilise riez tous
les acteurs de l'emploi
notamment sur le plan régional pour
faire en sorte que 2011 soit une année
de baisse sensible du chômage
aussi je me réjoui du travail accompli
et de cette évolution positive depuis
trois mois mais je souhaite connaître
vos engagements et les mesures que vous
comptez prendre pour le maintien d'une
action forte en faveur de l'emploi et
plus particulièrement celui des jeunes
et les plus de 55 ans car l'art et la
création d'emplois monsieur le ministre
reste notre priorité
merci mon cercueil la parole est à
monsieur xavier bertrand ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la santé de la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous l'avez dit il
n'est pas question un seul instant de
relâcher nos efforts au moment même où
nous venons de connaître une double
bonne nouvelle
la première c'est que le chômage a
reculé au mois de mars
parce qu'il y à 21000 sentent demandeurs
d'emploi en moins
c'est le chiffre le plus important de
baisse depuis février 2008
depuis février 2008 avant la crise
d'autre part trois mois de baisse à la
suite c'est la première fois depuis le
premier trimestre 2008 avant la crise
également et nous savons pertinemment
que quand nous parlons de sortie de
crise pour nos concitoyens
la sortie de crise c'est quand le
chômage aura reculer durablement
voilà la réalité alors bien évidemment
dans ces bonnes nouvelles nous devons
noter que le chômage des jeunes ne
cessent de reculer sur une année on est
à près de 7% de baisse ça n'est pas
assez mais qu'en revanche en revanche
les mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement notamment pour
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
de longue durée de plus de 50 ans
commence seulement à porter leurs fruits
que nous devons permettre vis-à-vis de
cela à la fois d'avoir un suivi
individualisé
ils sont toutes et tous en train d'être
reçus individuellement par les agents de
pôle emploi et l'autre par nous voulons
leur proposer formation et contrats
aidés et d'ailleurs je dis à toutes et
tous notamment à celles et ceux qui
exercent des responsabilités
départementales
je demande de répondre à l'appel du
gouvernement qui consiste à dire nous
pouvons ensemble prendre davantage de
contrats aidés
contrats aidés offert un chômeur de
longue durée qui est au rsa ça coûte
moins cher pour le département 411 euros
le petit 4 67 euros et à la fin du mois
c'est une fiche de paye plutôt qu'une
allocation sans activité voilà la
réalité de ce que nous proposons
aujourd'hui et nous pouvons ensemble
faire plus encore sur tous ces sujets
vous le savez également nous allons
continuer notamment à proposer de
nouvelles mesures pour la formation en
alternance l'apprentissage les contrats
de professionnalisation avec nadine
morano nous allons prendre de nouvelles
initiatives qui seront soumises
également au parlement et enfin le
dernier point c'est qu'il nous faut une
approche en matière d'emplois beaucoup
plus proche du terrain et il nous faudra
pour ça définir notamment une nouvelle
feuille de route pour pôle emploi
prenez l'exemple de la restauration tout
à l'heure avec frédéric lefebvre nous
avons signé l'avenant pour les métiers
de la restauration
et il faut bien voir que quand il ya eu
cette baisse de la tva le premier
objectif c'était l'emploi et c'est
l'emploi et que demain ils s'engagent à
avoir vingt mille recrutement de plus
chaque année mais que nous devons aussi
faire en sorte que l'on trouve les
demandeurs d'emploi pour pourvoir ces
postes et ça on ne saura pas le faire de
façon efficace au niveau national ou
régional
c'est bien au niveau local je le
revendique nous avons l'ambition de
faire reculer le chômage est une
approche pragmatique
c'est de cette façon aussi que l'on
redonne un emploi de l'espoir et de la
confiance à nos concitoyens
merci je suis ministre madame alima
boumédiene thiery pour le groupe
socialiste
j'avais la parole oui monsieur le
ministre je souhaitais attiré
l'attention dû ministre de la justice
sur le désarroi et la colère qui anime
le monde de la justice comme celui de la
police d'ailleurs deux maillons
indispensables d'une même chaîne
depuis plusieurs mois avocats et
magistrats s'inquiètent du déploiement
progressif de la justice je rappelle
notamment l'ampleur du rassemblement du
29 mars dernier et l'unité affichée par
les personnels de justice
cette colère s'amplifie avec le vote de
la loi sur la garde à vue en raison des
difficultés liées à son entrée en
application cette soit relative à la
garde à vue n'est qu'une illustration de
ce malaise du monde judiciaire
le gouvernement s'est retrouvé à devoir
faire appliquer dans la précipitation
une loi qui aurait dû être fondamental
depuis plusieurs années la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme alerte
la france sur la nécessité d'une réforme
de la garde à vue mais il aura fallu
attendre conseil constitutionnel qu'il
intervienne en juillet 2010 pour
qu'enfin vous vous penchiez sur cette
réforme
l'assemblée plénière de la cour de
cassation par des arrêts du 15 avril
2011 a décidé l'application immédiate de
cette loi le ministre a pris une
circulaire soit mais elle reste très
évasive quant à la façon concrète dont
on doit envisager les choses policiers
avocats magistrats sont unanimes cette
loi a été votée sans les moyens
nécessaires à sa bonne mise en oeuvre
déjà les acteurs du monde judiciaire
n'avait plus les moyens d'exercer leurs
missions dans des conditions acceptables
or l'entrée en vigueur non préparés de
cette loi n'a rien arrangé
le caractère dérisoire des ressources
qui lui sont alloués est à la hauteur du
peu de cas que la majorité fait de la
justice récemment monsieur le garde des
sceaux a déclaré que la justice
disposait maintenant de ressources y
compris humaines suffisantes pour son
fonctionnement
on va vous le savez cela il faut je
regrette qu'il ne soit pas là pour nous
répondre
aujourd'hui vous savez comment faire et
vous ne le savez pas en tout cas pour
mettre en oeuvre cette réforme de la
garde à vue qui nous est imposé et que
vous n'avez pas su anticiper
pourtant cela fait près de dix ans que
vous auriez dû la prévoir les locaux de
services de police et de gendarmerie
doivent être modernisées cette réforme
s'impose comme vous le savez elle ne
pourra que passer par le déblocage de
fonds vous devez également doté de plus
de moyens
les recours à l'aide vos pièges tout les
gardes à vue près de 100 millions
d'euros semble nécessaire les avocats
qui assisteront au titre de l'aide
judiciaire des gardes à vue sont
rémunérées en moyenne 4 68 de leurs
c'est réellement irrespectueux de leur
travail
alors il convient
aujourd'hui de prendre les mesures
nécessaires touquet les droits des
personnes gardées à vue soient respectés
que les avocats magistrats et policiers
puissent travailler dans des conditions
décentes
je souhaiterais savoir comment le
gouvernement compte prendre en compte
toutes les revendications des policiers
des avocats des magistrats
comment vous allez enfin donner à la
justice les moyens de fonctionner et de
permettre en effet l'application
effective de la réforme de la garde à
vue pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur françois baroin ministre du
budget des comptes publics de la
fonction publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs en madame le
sénateur
un mot tout d'abord pour définir le
cadre général de l'effort en matière de
politique publique autour de la justice
sous l'impulsion gouvernementale c'est
l'un des deux budgets qui est épargnée
par les efforts de réduction de déficits
c'est l'un des deux qui est en
augmentation avec celui l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche + 4 % cette
année je me permets juste pour nourrir
votre réflexion avoir une vision peut
être un peu plus objective de la réalité
du monde judiciaire
entre 2002 et 2009 les effectifs
pénitentiaires ont augmenté de 33 %
concernant les conseillers d'orientation
les conseillers de probation ont
augmenté de 55% et d' à l'horizon 2018
sous l'impulsion et la volonté du
président de la république
soixante dix mille places dans des
prisons dont le plan et les modalités
sont annoncés par le garde des sceaux
que je prie de bien vouloir excuser qui
est actuellement en déplacement en
province seront formalisées avant l'été
et il y aura donc une dynamique
supplémentaire et complémentaire pour
répondre aux sollicitations évidemment
de la société à travers l'autorité
judiciaire qui prononce des peines qui
doivent être appliqués dans ce cadre là
pour atterrir plus directement sur
l'angle de votre question portant sur
l'application de la garde à vue
pourquoi d'abord cette réforme vous
l'avez rappelé vous même le conseil
constitutionnel saisi d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité que de
constitutionnalité a donné sa décision
est rendue applicable immédiatement
ce dispositif c'est à dire la présence
de l'avocat en garde à vue dès la
première heure ceci a été confirmé par
la cour de cassation qui a validé sa
propre jurisprudence sur la base de la
jurisprudence constante
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui elle-même a justifié la présence au
titre des libertés publiques de l'avocat
dès la première heure dans cet esprit et
dans l'application immédiate
le gouvernement a décidé une application
instantanée de cette loi le ministre de
l'intérieur dont je salue la divisant la
diligence et la célérité avec laquelle
il a pris les dispositions pour les
officiers de police judiciaire a rendu
immédiatement opérationnel ce dispositif
où nous en sommes
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui très
simplement dans la portion des
discussions avec les barreaux et avec
les avocats
nous avons établi une proposition sur la
base de 300 euros hors taxe ce qui place
le financement et la rémunération des
avocats dans le cadre des gardes à vue
et dans le cadre des commis d'office au
niveau supérieur de toute la moyenne des
pays de l'union européenne je vous
renvoie précisément au stade de
rémunération en espagne en allemagne en
grande-bretagne au programme inclut de
ce point de vue la proposition du
gouvernement français est supérieure à
la moyenne des pays de l'union
européenne nous serons donc en temps en
heure et en rémunération à un niveau
d'exigence souhaité par l'application
des libertés publiques dans notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur simoneau et claude pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
pour 2 minutes 30 maximum la question
monsieur le président ce revers ça
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur tout
comme en métropole l'insécurité
progresse en nouvelle calédonie en effet
l'année d'année en année les chiffres de
la délinquance ne cesse d'augmenter avec
puce 4,45 % en 2010 alors que les
effectifs et les moyens des forces de
sécurité rapporté à la population son
supérieur à la métropole
en zone police la ville de nous-mêmes
concentre plus de 550 policiers dont 150
municipaux sans compter les 60
auxiliaire de proximité récemment créée
et financée par la province sud
ce constat m'amène à vous demander
monsieur le ministre à nos dit et une
rénovation en profondeur des services
concourant à la sécurité publique en
nouvelle calédonie car il semble y avoir
un problème apparemment la police
nationale ne manque ni de moyens humains
ni de moyens matériels cependant des
dysfonctionnements dans leur utile
leur utilisation et leur répartition
était dénoncée avec force ces derniers
temps pour preuve cette anecdote récente
où j'ai pu constater par moi-même qu'il
arrive que la brigade anticriminalité de
nouméa patrouille à pied faute de
véhicule de service rendu indisponible
en raison du zoo privé généralisée il
s'ensuit un sentiment éprouvé par la
population dans son ensemble que l'état
n'exerce pas pleinement faute de moyens
rationaliser sa mission de sécurité
publique
aussi monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie de bien vouloir nous donner
l'assurance que l'état adoptera adaptera
ses moyens pour lutter contre
l'insécurité grandissante en nouvelle
calédonie en général et a nommé en
particulier
par ailleurs alors que les chiffres de
la délinquance en nouvelle calédonie
atteignent des sommets
il apparaît curieusement que la lutte
contre la délinquance se fait moins
pressante en nouvelle calédonie qu'en
france métropolitaine
ne faudrait-il pas de redéployer les
effectifs et instituer une véritable
unité de police anti délinquance a nommé
un j'aimerais savoir monsieur le
ministre ce que vous avez à proposer en
la matière en effet un redéploiement des
effectifs et la création d'une véritable
unité de maintien de l'ordre par la
remise en cause de la compagnie
d'intervention est souhaitée
l'objectif serait de donner avec 7
unités une véritable mission de
sécurisation des biens et des personnes
actuellement 45 % seulement des appels
sur le 17 police secours sont satisfaits
par faute de moyens les moyens sont
certes présents mais il faut les
optimiser et la marge de progression
semble être important alors monsieur le
ministre que comptez vous faire
concrètement pour enfin redonner à la
nouvelle calédonie sa douceur de vivre
qu'elle semble avoir perdu
pour vous répondre comment le cas
monsieur guéant ministre de l'intérieur
de l'outre-mer des collectivités
territoriales vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais
d'abord vous demander la permission
monsieur sénateurs loueckhote d'apporter
quelques compléments aux indications
chiffrées que vous citiez à l'instant
d'abord je voudrais dire que
l'insécurité en métropole ne monte pas
elle n'augmente pas au contraire elle
est en recul l'an dernier elle a reculé
encore de 2%
et depuis 2002 elle a reculé de 17% pour
ce qui est de la nouvelle calédonie
c'est vrai qu'en 2010 la délinquance a
augmenté dans les proportions que vous
disiez je voudrais simplement rappeler
que l'année précédente elle avait baissé
de près de 3% de 94 exactement et de
cinq pour cent à nouméa et j'ajoute que
l'augmentation de 2010 est justifiée
notamment parce que dans le jargon
policier on appelle les hijas c'est à
dire les infractions révélées par
l'activité policière c'est à dire des
infractions qui ne donne pas lieu à
plainte mais que l'activité policière
met en évidence parce que l'activité
policière est importante
alors cela étant ce sénateur je suis
d'accord avec vous il ya toujours moyen
de mieux faire
et comme vous je ne suis pas satisfait
de la façon dont les choses se passent
en nouvelle calédonie et je dois dire
que je rejoins complètement la façon
constructive opérationnels dont vous
abordez les choses le haut commissaire a
demandé au directeur de la sécurité
publique de la nouvelle calédonie une
mission de réorganisation des services
qui doit lui être présenté le 20 mai
prochain
cette nouvelle organisation aura pour
but en particulier d'adapter tout le
dispositif policier à la réalité
concrète de la délinquance selon les
horaires selon les quartiers et j'ajoute
que non content de cette mission locale
j'ai demandé au directeur généra la
police nationale de faire en sorte
qu'une mission de la direction centrale
de la sécurité publique dès lors que
directeur
de la nouvelle-calédonie aura fait son
travail se rende sur place pour faire un
audit une expertise examiner
l'éventualité de la création d'unités
spécialisées dans le maintien de l'ordre
en tout cas je voudrais vous assurer que
pour le gouvernement il est très
important que les calédoniens soit en
sécurité
comme l'ensemble de leurs compatriotes
merci monsieur le ménage la parole est
maintenant notre collègue hugues
portelli pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire vous avez la parole
mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mise l'agriculture
de l'alimentation de la pêche de la
ruralité et de l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur le ministre la
sauvegarde de notre patrimoine forestier
est une priorité environnementale pour
laquelle monsieur le président la
république a rappelé aujourd'hui même
son engagement personnel
or depuis plusieurs années nous
assistons l'intensification des coupes
massives dans les forêts du val d'oise
c'est à dire les forêts de montmorency
de carnel et de l'isle adam malgré la
mobilisation de nombreux élus des
associations et des promeneurs pour la
seule forêt montmorency
nous sommes passés entre 2005 et 2009 de
10 mille mètres cubes d'arbres abattus à
21 milles soit plus du double des
augmentations la tendance n'a fait
qu'augmenter depuis ce qui veut dire que
nous aurons droit à des trous et
irréversible dans nos forêts durant plus
de cinquante ans ces destructions sont
tellement impressionnante que nous
sommes saisis d'une protestation
croissante des habitants qui croient que
ces coupes sont motivés par la
construction d'autoroutes ou
d'équipement de gros calibre ce qui
évidemment n'est pas le cas et face à
nos protestations
l'office national des forêts qui n'a
même pas été capable de procéder au
ramassage des arbres abattus lors de la
grande tempête de 1999 fait la sourde
oreille
monsieur le ministre il est primordial
de défendre notre patrimoine forestier
périurbain de défendre les paysages
sylvestre du val d'oise et de la
périphérie d'île de france et ce qui
constitue l'un des poumons verts
de notre région il en va également de la
sauvegarde de notre biodiversité
que comptez vous faire monsieur le
ministre pour faire cesser les coupes de
bois intensive
est il possible de classer rapidement
ses forêts en forêt de protection
et peut-on même envisagé un moratoire
sur les coupes programmée mais aussi mon
cher collègue pour vous répondre la
parole est à monsieur benoist apparu
secrétaire d'état en charge du logement
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je vous demande de bien vouloir
excuser tout d'abord bruno le maire qui
comme vous le savez est avec le
président de la république pour parler
fort et en corrèze
vous lui demandez d'envisager le
classement du massif forestier de
montmorency en forêt de protection et un
moratoire sur les coupes programmé ce
massif du val d'oise
d'une superficie de 4700 hectares ha sur
trois fonctions importantes pour la
population une fonction sociale
l'accueil du public les espaces de
loisirs une fonction de protection de la
biodiversité et de la ressource en eau
enfin est évidemment une fonction
économique avec la production de bois la
politique forestière dans les forêts
périurbaines repose sur un double
équilibre d'un côté l'expansion urbaine
bien évidemment mais de l'autre la
protection de ces espaces boisés la
région ile-de-france est évidemment
particulièrement concernée avec 21 mille
hectares susceptibles de faire l'objet
d'un tel classement
alors concernant le classement du massif
de montmorency en forêt de protection
vous le savez un dialogue est en cours
entre les services de la préfecture et
du ministère
l'engagement de cette procédure est
simplement soumise à une condition
préalable
sa comptable compatibilité avec la
présence d'un gisement important de
jyske exploité en souterrain et
d'intérêt national
enfin concernant la question des coupes
de bois effectuées dans ce massif
par le nf qui est en charge de la
gestion des forêts domaniales
elles sont conformes au schéma
d'aménagement 2004 2023 et le retard
pris dans le renouvellement des
peuplements au cours du précédent
aménagement a il est vrai entraîné un
vieillissement prématuré de la forêt de
cette forêt qui nécessite un effort de
régénération particulièrement important
et c'est dans ce cadre là que l'accueil
du public a été prise en compte par la
réalisation de coupe qui limite les
impacts visuels et qui préserve les
îlots paysager
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous en avons fini avec les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h15 pour l'examen
à proposition de loi tendant à renforcer
les moyens de contrôle et d'information
des groupes politiques de l'assemblée
nationale a donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
on se retrouve tout de suite ici sur ce
plateau avec nos invités des
parlementaires des ministres ensemble on
refait la séance
et ensemble donc nous allons refaire
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement avec nos invités qui
vont nous rejoindre dans quelques
instants sur ce plateau installé dans la
salle des conférences du sénat salle des
conférences qui se trouve juste à côté
de l'hémicycle de la haute assemblée
pour revenir
bien sûr sur l'ensemble des questions
des questions abordées
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle lors de
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
et puis je vous le rappelle également
cette information principale
cet après midi cet attentat au maroc à
marrakech qui a fait 14 morts le
gouvernement marocain a confirmé qu'il
s'agit bien d'une explosion meurtrière
sur ses quatorze morts il y aurait aux
étrangers des informations bien sûr à
confirmer
officiellement et peut-être que sur ce
plateau viendront nous rejoindre dans
quelques instants
des membres du gouvernement qui pourront
éventuellement nous apporter un peu plus
de précision donc sur cet attentat qui a
eu lieu à l'heure du déjeuner
aujourd'hui à marrakech en plein coeur
de marrakech sur la place djemaa el fna
fréquenté par de nombreux touristes va
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau tout de
suite le président de la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat jean bizet
bonjour merci d'être avec nous tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle guéant le
ministre de l'intérieur a précisé un
petit peu les modalités d'application
d'un nouveau jeune ken notamment un
renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières des également des gardes
frontières européens est ce que ce sont
des dispositifs véritablement de nouveau
faim pas spécialement si vous voulez ça
existe déjà au coeur du fonctionnement
de schengen mais dans des moments
d'exception tels que ce que nous vivons
il faut leur donner plus je dirais
d'efficacité de lisibilité
deux parmi les cinq critères qui a
annoncé tout à l'heure le ministre de
l'intérieur n'y a finalement rien de
véritablement neuf alors si parce que si
vous voulez pour le moment ce n'était
que 1 parfaitement mis en oeuvre
notamment les clauses de sauvegarde un
sur lequel si vous voulez nous n'avions
pas l'habitude de 2,2 les deux les
dimensionné et on rappelle façon pour
qu'ils n'y ont aucune ambiguïté sur ce
point que schengen en même titre que la
création de la monnaie unique est un
acquis fondamental de l'union européenne
mais siffler wilks schengen n'est pas la
libre circulation des immigrés
clandestins est ce qu'il faut pour que
schengen soit totalement mise en oeuvre
est ce qu'il faut un accord unanime des
membres de l'union européenne
on va disons que notamment il a précisé
monsieur le ministre a précisé
nouvelle gouvernance on verra comment le
conseil j'aille justice et affaires
intérieures va se prononcer le 12 mai
accor à mon avis je ne pense que tout le
monde sera d'accord
l'allemagne a pas l'air très disposé à
revoir les différentes modalités autour
de ça devienne il faut bien être
conscient que dans cette affaire il ya
une responsabilité particulière du pays
d'accueil mais que ses responsabilités
du pari d'accueil ne peuvent se
concevoir sans la solidarité de
l'ensemble des autres et amant parce que
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui à l'italie à
malte où à quelques autres ne peut se
concevoir sans la solidarité des autres
27 26 et amant oui il va falloir plus de
solidarité entre les différents pays
comme le sélectionnant inciter à cette
solidarité là moi je crois pas
l'influencé la vengeance que ce qui
s'est passé de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée ne peut se résoudre par tel
ou tel pays
et parallèlement nous n'avons pas évoqué
cela mais il y à un pendant de la
résolution de ce dossier
c est bien le développement économique
et social au sein même de ces pays
en d'autres termes l'union pour la
méditerranée qui a été repris par le
printemps barroso au travers de ce
protocole pour une démocratie et une
prospérité partagée doit être repensée
redimensionner financièrement donc
l'union pour la méditerranée pourrait
renaître de ses cendres finalement
en france elle est morte je mets mais
elle n'a pas été très sérieusement perdu
ta vie galles n'a pas été comprise peut
être insuffisamment explicités mais on
s'aperçoit qu'en fin de compte ce
concept était particulièrement
prémonitoire on a quand même
l'impression au travers de cette crise
que la commission européenne a été prise
en otage entre la france et l'italie est
ce que ça va aussi votre impression
disons que chacun a été un peu surpris
de la brutalité de l'émergence
je dirais du printemps arabe on ne peut
aujourd'hui a posteriori que s'en
réjouir
maintenant il faut corriger
effectivement la mise en oeuvre de tout
ce qui était prévu dans schengen d'où
l'intérêt également le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale ont créé une
commission de suivi pour justement être
très attentif à l'évolution de ce
dossier
on ne soit pas uniquement dans la
gesticulation politique parce que pour
beaucoup d'observateurs
c'était avant tout des clins d'oeil au
front national à l'extrême droite au néo
populisme en france comme en italie dans
la question est trop grave puisqu'il
cergy d'êtres humains pour se borner à
pour se borner à réagir au travers de
clin d'oeil c'est peut-être la position
du parti socialiste on va voir ça tout
de suite avec le sénateur jean pierre
sueur bonjour je sais pas si c'est
énorme je sais pas si vous avez entendu
ma question à un agent bizet quelle est
votre position vois ma position c'est
que nous devons être fidèles à ce qu'est
la france responsable et généreuse
fraternelle et lorsque l'on mesure ce
qui se passe en tunisie vous savez que
les tunisiens ils ont accueilli deux
cent mille réfugiés libyens
ils l'ont fait et nous nous avons un
certain nombre de milliers de tunisiens
qui viennent en europe qu'est ce qu'on
leur dit on ne peut quand même pas leur
dire on vous renvoie la mère et moi je
savais ce que dira précisément quelle
est la volonté pays sociale et leur dit
d'abord que e on prend en compte les
personnes qui sont là en dessous du
boulevard périphérique et qu'on les
traite comme des êtres humains
premièrement parce que vous savez qu'il
existe un malade au lendemain d'un
permis de séjour tentatives on traite la
question de manière humaine c'est à dire
que on ne cherche pas les renvoyer dans
le premier avion
deuxièmement eux on met en oeuvre les
accords de schengen
au lieu de vouloir les démanteler et on
dit que l'on peut accueillir un certain
nombre de personnes mon ami michel
rocard a dit on ne peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde mais il avait
ajouté
mais la france doit y prendre toute sa
part or par rapport à la tunisie
il est très important de ne pas envoyer
de messages négatifs par rapport à ces
êtres humains qui au péril de leur vie
sur des rafiots ils traversent la
méditerranée ip à des passeurs et ils
sont là on peut on doit quand même les
traités comme des êtres humains
je demande de l'humanité je sais bien
que on ne pourra pas accueillir tout le
monde c'est parfaitement vrai et c'est
pourquoi sûr qu'il faut bien vous êtes
votre choix à l'art en question inverse
qui sont dans la loi il faut des
critères précis bien sûr mais dans le
cas d'afflux pour des circonstances
particulières il existe une directive de
2001 qui donne le droit au séjour
temporaire c'est prévu par l'europe
il faudrait que tous les pays d'europe
se mettent d'accord pour appliquer cela
ça ne peut pas être seulement la sphère
de l'italie ça doit être la sphère de
l'ensemble des pays d'europe et la
france doit il prendre sa part j'ajoute
une chose et après la réponse de la mise
et oui oui et j'ajoute d'une chose c'est
que nous devons aider extraordinairement
au développement de la tunisie
parce que c'est vrai que la réponse pour
les tunisiens
tam ont été développés sont à la france
oui mais il faut faire beaucoup plus
haut niveau de l'europe
la tunisie'' demande être un partenaire
privilégié si nous ne voulons pas que le
chômage se développe en tunisie il faut
aider et il faut était d'autant plus que
ce peuple il a recouvré la liberté et
pour vivre en liberté il faut sans doute
créer les bonnes conditions jean-pierre
la réponse de jean bizet à la fois sur
ces questions humanitaires sur
l'application de la directive et puis
également effectivement sur le déblocage
de fonds pour aider la tunisie à se
reconstruire
humanisme oui la france a une large
traditions et les hors de question qu'on
abandonne si vous voulez cet état
d'esprit et dieu merci si vous voulez ça
transcende nos sensibilités politiques
ceci dit la france comme vous l'avez dit
mon cher collègue ne peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde à prendre sa
part
elle doit prendre sa part certes mais
l'avenir des tunisiens il n'est pas en
france
l'avenir des tunisiens il est dans leur
propre pays d'où cette notion union pour
la méditerranée sans faire de politique
politicienne qui n'a pas été bien
comprise par les uns ou les autres qui
est redimensionné désormais au niveau
communautaire et je vous fais une
proposition qui n'est pas la mienne en
fin de compte mais je la restitue à son
auteur qui est celle de denis badré les
les avoirs de monsieur landré les ordres
d'un centre il devrait précisément non
seulement être gelée mais être
réutilisés omer précisément de prêts
relais pour servir à développer ce pays
et à permettre aux tunisiens de rester
travailler et développer leur propre
vous savez que la justice tunisienne
s'en occupe
nous avons reçu avec gérard larcher
monsieur ben achour qui est chargé de la
future constitution de la tunisie vous
savez que c'est formidable ce qu'ils
font par exemple dans l'assemblée
constituante cher perrine tarneaud on
aussi jeune easy cet homme soit la
parité absolue
donc c'est un pays qui a un espoir
extraordinaire pour la démocratie
il veut se développer et il faut que
l'europe toute entière face un grand
effort parce que l'union pour la
méditerranée ça a été quelques paroles
mais très peu d'actes donc il faut aider
et par rapport à ces malheureux qui sont
là dans leur barque et qui arrive qu'on
les traite
humainement quand j'entends une député e
dire il faut les renvoyer à la mer jeudi
que la république française parce que
c'est la france elle a un coeur et
qu'elle ne traite pas les gens comme ça
jean bizet peut-être un mot pour finir
ce débat sur ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui au maroc cet attentat à
marrakech
il y aurait attentats officiels ça vient
d'être confirmée par le gouvernement
marocain il y aurait 14 morts pour
l'instant dont onze étrangers votre
réaction
écoutez vous vous me l'apprenez tout
acte terroriste et hautement condamnable
mais on sent très bien que cette partie
du monde et sous une énorme tension
je salue ces jeunes
qui au travers je dirais d'un formidable
espoir sont en train de redessiner tout
ce paysage je dirais aux abords de
l'europe et donc à mon avis avec du bon
sens de l'humanisme
mais également je dirais une ferme
application des traités des accords de
schengen s'agit pas de je dirais de
transformer schengen simplement
d'appliquer ce qui existe notamment le
fait qu un titre de séjour accordés par
l'italie ne vaut pas un mandat ni de
circuler des mois et des mois dans
l'europe de façon illégale mais aussi de
ne pas cela jean bizet tripoter schengen
parce que si on démolit schengen ont
défait l'europe pour moi je crois qu'il
n'y a dit sue par rapport au
développement du maghreb dans l'est de
la coopération que si l'europe toute
entière 6 mai et je suis pour un plan
marshall pour qu'on aide ces pays
les pays arabes du monde arabe qui
recouvre la liberté
il faut vraiment leur donner la main par
des actes symboliques par rapport à ceux
qui sont là mais aussi par une vraie
politique de coopération et
développement
je crois qu'on est d'accord là dessus
mon cher reconnaît qu on est d'accord
sur le fond pas sur la sémantique
influença plan marshall ou union pour la
méditerranée l'essentiel les sens et que
les moyens construire lancer large en
travers des écoutes et merci beaucoup
jean bizet d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau jean arthuis le présent la
commission des finances du sénat va
prendre votre place
juste pour finir sur l'immigration jean
pierre sueur
si on précède un petit peu le projet du
parti socialiste en matière
d'immigration vous proposer une
régulation progressif mais sur quels
critères proposons une rue une
régularisation
si vous voulez constante dire que je
crois qu'il ne faut pas dire tout
progressive de régularisation ou dire au
contraire un beau jour on ouvre toutes
les vannes
il faut que les anciens voire des
régularisations constante sur des
critères humanitaires passe
il y a le droit d'asile parce qu'il y à
la protection temporaire ça existe
deuxièmement sur des critères de vie
familiale parce que on a le droit de
vivre en famille troisièmement des
critères professionnels et des critères
d'études
je suis très frappé des grandes
difficultés que connaissent des
étudiants et notamment des étudiants
tunisiens qui veulent venir faire des
études en france et qui se heurtent à
des obstacles administratifs
considérables qui n'existe pas dans
d'autres pays
et quand on accueille des jeunes de pays
comme la tunisie l'algérie le maroc
l'egypte qui viennent faire leurs études
en france n'oublions pas que c'est un
formidable investissement pour la france
et pour la culture française donc
accueillons tout cela il peut il faut
qu'il y ait des critères bien sûr nous
voulons des critères qu'ils soient
larges et qui soit responsable et puis
qu'il y ait une politique constante de
coopération et en l'espèce ce grand
projet d'un formidable plan de
coopération avec les pays du maghreb
parce que cette liberté qui arrivent
dans les pays arabes
eh bien il faut pas que ça retombe et
pour ça il faut jouer la terre
développement et de la coopération merci
à vous merci jean bien sûr d'un devenu
jean arthuis bonjour je rappelle donc
vers le président de la commission des
finances du sénat la commission des
finances du sénat qui demande au
gouvernement sans doute un peu plus de
rigueur l'année prochaine oui parce que
nous avons eu hier soir pour la première
fois examiné un projet de stabilité un
programme de stabilité qui est la
feuille de route que le gouvernement
communique à la coalition de bruxelles
pour indiquer que le cap qui est pris
c'est bien celui du retour à l'équilibré
des finances publiques pas l'exercice
tout à fait nouveau depuis vingt ans les
gouvernements successifs ont envoyé à
bruxelles
d
programme de stabilité optimiste qui
aboutissait touche à l' équilibre des
finances publiques ne s'est jamais
vérifié mais là visiblement vous trouvez
pour la première fois à riom la première
fois le parlement examine ce programme
avant qu'ils ne soient transmis à
l'homme sa vie et nous votons nous
donnons à la vie et la vie que nous
avons donné tu es dans la vie pour dire
que le cap et le bon celui de
l'équilibré
les hypothèses macroéconomiques de 2 5%
et sans doute volontariste et
excessivement optimiste ce qui est
fantastique c'est que politiquement il
ya une espèce de convention le parti
socialiste a rendu public récemment son
projet pour 2012
et comme par hasard pour équilibrer ses
comptes et bien il parle lui aussi d'une
croissance à 2,5
c'est là peut-être un petit déni de
réalité et donc nous appelons le
gouvernement à ne pas sous-estimer
délivrer l'ampleur des efforts accomplis
remise pour équilibrer les comptes
publics excès d'optimisme en termes de
croissance
benoist apparu chez nous a rejoints
secrétaire d'état du gouvernement chargé
du logement le gouvernement d'un point
de vue des finances publiques en parle
finances publiques je suis désolé dans
un déni de réalité
selon jean arthuis selon la commission
des finances du sénat trop optimiste en
cela la commission à propos de la
croissance et l'hypothèse de croissance
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale comme du cdh a
d'ailleurs est dans son rôle d'alerté
fortement le gouvernement sur les
déficits publics
on est juste rappeler quand même que
c'est vraiment l'un des nos objectifs
prioritaires que les résultats 2011 2010
pardon sont meilleurs que l'on ne
pensait alors c'est vrai les prévisions
de croissance parce que c'est une raison
si l'on présente chrome et thimister
c'est toujours une incertitude
je vous rappelle quand même que en 2009
si mes souvenirs sont bons on avait une
prévision de croissance négative
on a fini à 1 à 1,5 donc les prévisions
de croissance est toujours beaucoup
d'incertitudes
si je prends mon secteur d'activité on a
largement 30% de plus de construction
depuis six mois
que les six mois qui précèdent et donc
on a vraiment par exemple dans mon sujet
une croissance exceptionnelle tant mieux
le logement c'est ce qui fournit le plus
d'emplois donc je sais pas si on est
optimiste ou pas optimiste il faut bien
une prévision de croissance
en tout état de cause j'ai une certitude
nous sommes dans la bonne voie et nous
avons pris des engagements forts nous
les respectons il est impératif quand on
joue tous 13-14 nous respections
l'ensemble nos objectifs en matière de
prévision des dépenses publiques et jean
arthuis tout cela pour dire qu'il ne
faut pas sous-estimer l'ampleur de
l'effort à accomplir pour réduire la
dépense publique est sans doute pour
améliorer la recette public notamment
par la suppression d'un certain nombre
de niches fiscales je partage d'autant
plus que vient dire jean arthuis que je
pense qu'on peut faire les
démonstrations nouvelle et intelligente
je suis convaincue mais convaincu qu'on
peut faire beaucoup mieux avec beaucoup
moins et je vais prendre un exemple nous
avons fait la réforme du prêt à taux
zéro là quelques semaines nous avions
une dépense de 4,5 milliards d'euros
répartis dans trois outils on l'a
transformé tout ça en un seul outil
dépenses nouvelles 3 milliards d'euros
bien qu'on a fait économiser la
puissance publique 1,5 milliard d'euros
et on a un outil maintenant qui est
beaucoup plus efficace que les trois
outils précédent et réunis et on fera
beaucoup plus d'accès dans la propriété
cette année objectif 350 milles par
rapport à 200 me l'année dernière on
peut faire et on peut le démontrer qu'on
peut économiser de l'argent en ayant des
outils beaucoup plus efficace au service
de la population sur le bilan des quatre
années de nicolas sarkozy on a
l'impression aujourd'hui comme un peu
dans le reniement il ya des mesures
phares qui sont abandonnés je pense au
bouclier fiscal
je pense au discours de nicolas sarkozy
hier sur le numérique avec un mea culpa
sur la loi hadopi savez si je prends
l'exemple de la loi hadopi
permettez moi de vous dire qu'il ya que
ce clinicien qui n'ont aucun résultat
oui il peut y avoir telle ou telle
législation qui finalement à l'épreuve
des faits les mamans décès à la non mais
c'est pas du ballon d'essai si
effectivement quel est le drame de la
france c'est qu'on est dans l'incapacité
totale de juger véritablement nos
politiques publiques
moi ce dont je rêve c'est quoi c'est
qu'au bout de six mois d'une politique
publique on puisse nous dire ça marche
ça marche pas on changeait d'âme tout de
suite les choses et qu'on n'attende pas
cinq ans pour changer un dispositif qui
ne marche pas ça marche pas on en tire
les conséquences tout de suite c'est ça
la bonne politique publique
c'est pas du reniement c'est de se dire
que oui il y avait un problème hadopi il
y avait un problème de taille des
téléchargement illégal on a ici une
solution pour le régler si ça marche on
continue si ça marche pas on en tire les
conséquences et 800 drame sans
considérer que cet arménien un reniement
je prends mon exemple mon prêt taux zéro
+ j ça fait trois mois qu'il existe mais
j'y tiens ça fait 3 - qui les travaille
à gérer un élément la semaine dernière
au bout de trois mois d'exercice pour le
rendez vous en pensez quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer qu'est-ce
qu'il faut changer tout de suite pour
que ça marche il faut qu'on évalue nos
politiques publiques et non pas ceux
d'hier sous prétexte que j'ai fait une
annonce c'est gravé dans le marbre
il faut a rien changé mais ça les
parlementaires le fond il évalue les
politiques publiques seulement celle
aussi les évalue les traces et les
abonnements
change rien c'est le rôle de manca
d'évaluer les politiques publiques en
effet mais est-ce que c'est suffisamment
écoutés du gouvernement alors eh bien
oui de temps en temps mais je pense
qu'on légifère beaucoup trop on crée une
instabilité législatives qui rend la loi
incompréhensible il ya trop de lois qui
devient des véhicules de communication
alors il ya de l'annonce mais il peut
arriver que la communication se
substituer à l'action dimanche nous
serons le 1er mai le front national
organise son grand rassemblement annuel
marine le pen a dit qu'elle voulait
défendre la liberté syndicale elle
poursuit son offensive dans les classes
ouvrières ça vous inquiète
moi j'ai pas d'inquiétude particulière à
avoir par rapport au positionnement
politique du front national du parti
socialiste qui vous voulez nous
poursuivons nous notre route
moi je n'ai pas l'intention de me
prononcer tous les samedis matin tous
les dimanches matins ou quand vous
voulez sur l'option prise par marine le
pen ou l'option prise par martine aubry
au parent qui vous voulez nous va bien
passer les dernières enquêtes qu'elle
séduit de plus en plus populaire je vais
juste simplement dire la chose suivante
continuons nous préoccuper que du ps et
de marine le pen et là on est sûr de
perdre tous nos électeurs
assumons nos positions assumons notre
stratégie défendant notre bilan
prononçons et travaillant sur notre
projet est effectivement nous aurons une
stratégie pour la présidentielle de 2012
dans un premier temps il faut travailler
sur le bilan il faut revendre continuer
à expliquer ce que nous avons fait qui
est formidable depuis depuis quatre ans
et il faut qu'on ouvre des perspectives
nouvelles sur un projet nouveau sans se
préoccuper ce que font les autres
à force de regarder les autres ont subi
soit même très bien passé un conseil
pourrait peut-être donner à d'autres
membres du gouvernement
merci beaucoup venant apparu d'être venu
sur notre plateau peut-être une réaction
sur marine le pen la liberté syndicale
qu'elle va défendre dimanche 1er mai
jean arthuis je crois qu'il faut que
chacun soit sur sa trajectoire sur ses
convictions sa vision et il est urgent
d'être soi même et de ne pas courir vers
les extrêmes
la mondialisation est là et ce matin
nous avions un débat sur une proposition
de loi du groupe socialiste sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés mais at on bien
conscience que à l'heure de la
globalisation de la mondialisation
tous les pays sont à la recherche de
bonnes mesures pour asseoir l'impôt
c'est peu dire que les lois nationales
deviennent de pure gesticulation
lorsqu'on est en phase de groupes
multinationaux et donc à l'heure où nous
avons à considérer ces problèmes
je pense que plus d'europe sans doute
plus d'europe fédérale nous permettrait
de définir des régulations effective en
matière économique en matière financière
en matière fiscale
le rêve en matière de sécurité
d'immigration elle matière de sécurité
également et au vote le chemin progrès
pour une gouvernance qui tend vers le
fédéralisme en europe
très bien merci beaucoup d'être venu sur
le plateau on accueille maintenant le
sénateur socialiste socialiste pardon
david assouline bonjour vous vous avez
posé tout à l'heure une question au
gouvernement sur le sort des otages
français dans le monde est ce que d'une
part il a été satisfait de la réponse
est ce que vous avez des informations
un petit peu plus précise je peux
concevoir que sur le plan public ne
puisse pas donner trop de détails je
voulais surtout qu'on en parle dans
l'hémicycle parce qu'il faut que les
politiques soient au diapason de ce qui
se passe dans la société civile au
niveau local on en parle parce que le
pire pour eux c'est l'oubli
et puis je voulais entendre que le
gouvernement faisait tout qu'il informer
les familles
à la seconde vie notamment pour les
reins visiblement les négociations
avancent que ce soient les otages d'aqmi
au niger au mali niger ou alors les deux
otages les deux journalistes français
retenus en otage en afghanistan et nous
a pas dit ça mais en même temps il a
montré une détermination à sur tout ce
qui m'importait c'est qu'on nous dise
qu'on veut les ramener vivants et qu'on
fait tout pour cela parce que bien
entendu il peut y avoir des inquiétudes
on sait que nos forces sont là bas
qu'elle souvent des opérations et c'est
une inquiétude qu'il faut lever et je
répète il faut continuer à en parler
partout où ça un petit mot peut-être sur
hadopi c'est un dossier qui vous
intéresse et hier l'elysée a reconnu des
erreurs de conduite dans la loi ce que
vous êtes satisfait de ce revirement de
nicolas sarkozy je suis bien entendu
satisfait convienne à nos arguments
enfin non mais franchement moi qui ai
passé des dizaines d'heures dans sept et
six missiles pour expliquer ce qui
allait se passer que c'est hadopi était
inadapté c'était une digue face à une
déferlante vous êtes qu'il savait voir
ce que vous aviez justice pour vraiment
faire que les choses et que quand on
fait une loi pour punir quelque chose et
qu'on ne peut pas l'appliquer
eh bien on encourage au contraire à
transgresser la loi dont on l'a on a dit
tout ça apparemment il se rend compte
que nous avions raison
je peux être que satisfait mais en même
temps quand on nous parle d'hadopi 3
j'espère que cette fois ci on écoutera
les principaux intéressés et ceux qui
connaissent le sujet pour pas faire les
mêmes bêtises
un petit mot du parti socialiste avant
de
d'interviewer maurice leroy qui nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau dites-moi la
bagarre a démarré il faut pas changer à
chaque fois parce que vous le décidez de
tonton je suis pas non 17 verges
on écoute les uns il y a quelques jours
tout le monde disait et c'est la réalité
le ton a changé il ya un petit sourire
il ya une bonne ambiance unanimité ses
mains qui se lèvent sur le projet un
socle ensemble et aussi les critiques
notamment du côté des strauss kahniens
contre hollande non mais je serais parti
trop vite ce qui divise le parti
c'est vrai pour lancer votre opinion
vaut aussi par contre vie de françois
hollande en opinion ce les gens parce
comme ils veulent
c'est leur stratégie la seule chose
qu'il faut garder c'est que on a deux
mois pour bien faire connaître notre
projet nous sommes d'accord avec pour
maître au coeur du débat public
nos propositions ensuite il sera temps
de martine aubry
ensuite il sera temps c'est martine
aubry s'est tous les dirigeants du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui qui font une
tournée en france sera plus de 100
réunions départementales
il y à laurent fabius il y à bertrand
delanoë il ya pierre moscovici il ya
vincent peillon y harlem désir il ya
benoît hamon il y à henri emmanuelli
toutes les sensibilités sont entrain de
d'aller vers les français pour
convaincre ce moment est important parce
qu'ils attendent de nous non seulement
le projet mais une unité après bien
entendu il y aura un choix démocratique
mais si on affiche le plus longtemps
possible cela est bien ce choix sera un
choix démocratique et non pas une
division de plus et moi en tous les cas
c'est mon point de vue c'est la façon
dont je vois les choses
merci beaucoup david assouline maurice
leroy bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous publiez gelé pas avec moi
ces temps ci un livre mais qu'on aura le
présent l'occasion de présenter sans
doute sur le plateau de public sénat
un autre jour comme on parle et là des
primaires socialistes vient vous vous
roulez pour jean louis borloo
ça sent quand même difficile à la
constitution d'un pôle autour de jean
louis borloo
que ce soit à l'intérieur de l'hémicycle
à l'assemblée nationale ou en dehors de
l'ump
nous verrons bien si plus difficile de
parler de mon livre qui est qui sort
aujourd'hui effectivement librairie
c'est parole d'affranchis aux éditions
du cherche midi voilà ce pour vous
faciliter la tâche
écoutez nous verrons bien avant même de
parler de candidature au centre il ya
une question qui est majeure c'est vous
aviez jean arthuis juste avant moi c'est
le rassemblement et nous sommes en train
de le faire et ça c'est une bonne chose
y compris pour la majorité
présidentielle
nous sommes en train de rassembler les
centristes du nouveau centre
ceux de jean arthuis de l'alliance
centriste le parti radical de jean louis
borloo qui à son corps et durer et jean
marie bockel qui dirige le mouvement de
la gauche moderne donc déjà rassemblés
c'est la première tâche le nouveau
centre d'hervé morin un conseil national
le 7 mai le parti radical se réunit le
14 mars carla mais il a commencé par
rassembler de nouveau la famille
centriste déjà une bonne nouvelle mais
qu'il faut aller au sein de l'assemblée
nationale et je n'ai jamais cru c'est à
titre personnel ce que je vous dis là je
n'ai jamais cru les groupes sont
constitués ici pardon d'ailleurs c'est
fait ici au sénat le groupe centriste
écoutez moi mais oui mais je suis
curieux moi je réponds aux questions que
vous posez vous demander si ça doit se
faire ça pas besoin de se faire au sénat
c'est fait il ya même des élus modem
avait vu au groupe centriste du sénat
locaux groupe centriste du sénat ils
sont même à l'avant-garde et visionnaire
puisque vous avez lé nouveau centre
l'alliance centriste
et le modem donc ces faits au sénat à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons un
groupe présidé par françois sauvadet qui
est le groupe du nouveau centre et nous
verrons bien ce qui se passe je vous
avais déjà ce qui compte c'est qu'au
niveau des formations politiques
nous nous rassemblions c'est le cas
c'est donc une bonne nouvelle
vous allez être candidat aux
sénatoriales je serai candidat aux
sénatoriales web et vous espérez pouvoir
conserver un groupe centriste
ici au sénat a valu aux deux tiers des
membres ce groupe sont honorables vous
savez je suis cependant compliqué non ce
sera pourquoi ce serait compliqué vous
savez les centristes surtout rassembler
pour le coup il n'y a aucune raison pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de groupe centriste au
sénat en septembre prochain par en
octobre puisque ça se réunira en octobre
maintenant
merci beaucoup maurice leroy cher il y
en a plus beaucoup de temps pour
philippe dominati
non vous réinvite pour votre livre qui
sort donc aujourd'hui merci d'avarice
avec nos philippe dominati chez désolé
il nous reste à peine deux minutes
justement concernant les sénatoriales la
constitution de la liste de la majorité
présentielle à paris c'est compliqué
c'est chantal jouanno qui va la conduire
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
décision du chef de l'état parce qu'elle
a été prise à l'elysée cette décision
suit d'abord ravi que le chef de l'état
ait choisi la stratégie que catherine
dumas et moi-même appuyons impulsé
c'était de rassembler la majorité
présidentielle mais derrière qui bavent
derrière les meilleurs et on fera
constitué la meilleure piste possible
face à la gauche à paris visiblement
c'est chantal jouanno qui a été choisi
pour quoi on est en train de constituer
tous là où il ya une orientation donnée
par le chef de l'état autour de chantal
jouanno autour de moi autour de
catherine dumas au tour de ceux qui ont
l'expérience de mener des combats à
paris des dialogues on est rétablie avec
les maires d'arrondissement avec les
personnalités qui comptent à paris à une
rencontre est prévue avec les élus
parisiens et donc c'est en train de se
faire décision pour quand on pour la mi
mai très probablement
comme tout le monde au même rythme pour
que tout le monde mais on travaille dans
le bon sens d'accord avec pour
l'efficacité très bien m'écouter merci
pour ces précisions philippe dominati on
en reparlera bien sûr sur l'antenne de
public sénat
merci à tous d'avoir suivi en direct ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
est très bonne après midi à tous sur la
chaîne parlementaire vous prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
c'est à 19h le journal présenté par
michel grossiord et à 22 heures
celui de sonia mabrouk